The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: So this
is the first true review
session in 18.085.
The last Wednesday, the
first Wednesday afternoon,
was a brief review of
topics in linear algebra.
But now we're into the course.
We've done four lectures
on the first four sections
of the textbook and one
homework problem in and back
and a second homework
set for next Monday.
So I'm ready for any questions,
including questions that are
on the homework if necessary.
But anything at all.
Or maybe I'll just
ask whether the pace,
so this is really informal.
Is the pace of the course, now
today's lecture had a lot in it
as I realized when I saw
that the board was still
full of 18.085 and
there was a little more
still to do because we didn't
finish the matrix part.
But are you okay with the
sort of speed of the course?
So that'll be one question.
And then, what about specifics?
Somebody start off if you will.
Anybody.
Yes, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Well, actually
I had a question
about the lecture earlier today.
PROFESSOR STRANG:
Okay, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I was just going to
look it up in the text, but.
PROFESSOR STRANG:
That's alright.
AUDIENCE: But haven't
had a chance to.
But, okay, so I'm
not really sure
how you take the
initial conditions
and apply them to
the ramp function
to actually get a solution.
PROFESSOR STRANG: So that's
what luckily happens to be still
here on the board, right?
We've got these boundary--
I would call them
boundary conditions.
So this is definitely,
we're in a part of math
that's about boundary
value problems
more than-- time
isn't in the picture.
I mean later time will
get into the picture.
So with this particular
example, the general solution
is a standard ramp at the point
a where things are happening.
Plus the C+Dx, the usual.
So that's a particular solution.
That particular solution has the
right behavior at the impulse.
By the right behavior, I mean
that the second derivative
of the ramp is a delta and
when I put the ramp at a,
then the delta
will show up at a.
And when I put on
that minus sign
it'll mean that the second
derivative is minus the delta.
So the slope will step down.
So that's a particular solution.
But that by itself, what
does that equal at zero?
And what does that equal at
one if you remember the ramp?
So let me just draw
that ramp again.
So the ramp was really based
on, centered at the point a.
And I'll put it
with a minus sign.
So it came along
there and down there.
And now suppose this is
one end of our interval
and that's the other end.
So is that ramp the
answer to our problem?
No.
Well it happens to satisfy
this boundary condition,
happens to start out at zero.
But it doesn't end up at zero.
So just like every particular
solution we need a little more.
We have to include
more solutions
because that was only one.
All those are equally
good solutions.
If I add C+Dx, the second
derivative of that is zero,
so it doesn't spoil
anything at all.
On the contrary, it
adds more solutions.
I mean the great
thing we're using here
is that our equations
are linear and when
zero's on the
right-hand side-- notice
there's no arbitrary constant.
I'm not putting an
arbitrary constant
on that particular solution.
Is one particular
solution plus a
subspace if I use that language.
A lot of solutions to
the-- All the solutions
to the problem with zero
on the right-hand side.
And these are the
solutions, these
are the null space guys,
the ones that have zero
on the right-hand side.
Now we need those.
And the effect of those
will be to move that ramp.
And effectively, what
are they going to do?
They're going to swing that
ramp around, it'll stay a ramp.
But instead of being
level here, it'll go up.
And instead of going down
there, it'll go down there.
It'll be the same
ramp, with still
that slope dropped by one.
Slope went down by
minus one and that's not
going to change here.
The slope will still
go down by minus one.
But now I've just adjusted
it so that it goes through
the-- it satisfies the
boundary conditions.
And in the second problem
with the free end,
again, here's my ramp.
But now I'm going to adjust it.
And what happened?
It just needed
adjustment upwards.
Because this was the zero,
this was the u=0 fixed guy.
And now if I'm doing
u'(0)=0, the free guy,
I can lift the whole thing up.
So you see, I just
lifted it up to the point
where it came out right there.
So in this case I just
needed a C. And in this case
I just needed a Dx.
And in other cases I
might have needed both.
A little bit of C
and a little of Dx.
Anyway that's what was--
maybe that's sort of repeating
what we did today a little bit.
But mechanically it's just,
we've got a particular solution
and we've got the
complete solution
and then we just have
to choose C and D
and we've got two
conditions to do it with,
the two boundary conditions.
Could have other
boundary conditions.
Now, what about, here's a, yeah.
I guess what will often happen
in these review sessions is
I get on a roll and I just
keep, carry on with it.
You know, you start me with
a question and I can't stop.
So I'll go a little longer but
then I really will stop, ready
for the next one.
So we haven't discussed
the free-free. u(0) equal--
u', sorry, free is u'.
That's free at the left
and free at the right.
What's up with that?
What's the solution to that?
Again, I'm looking for
-u'' equal an impulse.
With those two boundary
conditions, free-free.
And do you know what's
going to happen?
No solution.
Now it'd be interesting
to see why not.
Why no solution?
Well one way to do it is try.
Other right-hand sides
could have a solution.
So it's not just that this is--
something's the matter here.
Specifically, that right-hand
side and most right-hand sides
will fail.
But let's just see
it with this one.
Why does that fail?
Well you can see I can't,
the slope here is zero
and the slope here is minus one.
If I adjust those
I can't get, this
is asking me to get
slope zero at both ends.
I can't do that, right?
Yeah, just not possible for me
to-- This will add a straight
line but it's the
same straight--
I can't get a ramp that
comes flat at both ends
because there's-- once I say
what it's doing at the ends,
I've got it.
And you see what I mean?
I'm looking for one that
starts flat and ends flat
and that's not in my
family of solutions.
That problem just
doesn't have a solution.
So that's one way to do it,
is look at the solutions
and realize you can't satisfy
both boundary conditions.
Another way might be this.
This is a little bit deeper
way and it leads to something
better.
Suppose I take the integral.
So this is an equation
that's supposed to hold.
Let me integrate both
sides from zero to one.
So there's the idea
I'm putting in now.
To go a little
further, to discover
when this has a solution.
Or let me take more
generally, -u''=f(x).
So some other load.
Not necessarily a point load,
not necessarily a uniform load,
but maybe some other load.
And now my boundary conditions,
I'm trying to do free-free.
And usually no solution.
But let's just see why and
when there might be a solution.
The key idea is integrate
from zero to one.
What do I get on
the right-hand side?
Well, I get the integral
of f, whatever it is,
and I would call
that the total load.
Fair enough?
The total load of-- If
it was a delta function,
the total load would be one and
it would be all in one spot.
If it was uniformly
over the whole interval,
well I guess that would
also integrate to one,
so the total load would
be one spread out.
But it could be a mixture of
the two, could be a few delta
functions, whatever.
What happens when I integrate
the left side from zero to one?
Can you do that one?
The integral from zero to one.
There's that dopey
minus sign. u''dx.
What do I get?
Why do I say that's a good idea?
If I integrate the
second derivative
I get the first derivative.
The integral of the
second derivative
will be the first
derivative with the minus.
So it's minus the
first derivative.
And what do I do now?
I plug in the end points, right?
You integrate.
I'm integrating zero to one.
So I've found the integral.
I've put zero to one in there.
So what is that?
That's minus the
derivative at one
plus the derivative at zero.
And now, what's that?
That's zero.
By my boundary
conditions, that's zero.
So what have I found?
I've found that if these are the
boundary conditions, then when
I integrate the left side
it's going to give me zero.
So when, what loads
could be okay?
What loads f(x) could allow
me to solve this equation?
The condition will
be I need, what do I
need for the total load to be
able to solve this equation?
The integral of the
left side was zero
so the integral of the right
side had better be zero.
So that's the condition.
If I have these
boundary conditions,
then my problem is singular.
Usually no solution.
It's like having
a singular matrix.
It's like having this particular
singular matrix, of course.
Whoops, not that one.
Let me get the plus sign
in the right position.
That's a plus.
-1; -1, 2, -1; -1, 1.
Right?
This is the discrete version
with a zero slope at both ends.
It's our T matrix.
No, what matrix is it?
B. It's our B matrix, both ends.
I'll just come back here and
then I'll do the discrete one.
So tell me a load
that we could handle?
A load we could handle.
So the integral has to be zero.
So suppose my load has
a delta function at a.
Well that integral is one.
So can you fix that,
change that load
or do something, maybe
put on another load
to get a total load of zero?
What shall I do?
Add another guy
with a minus sign.
In other words,
maybe this, a delta
function at some other point b.
Well, that would do it.
I believe we could
solve that problem.
Even with these bad
boundary conditions.
We could solve that problem.
Because the total load would
be, one from that, minus one
from that, the total
load would be zero.
In other words, what would
are solution look like?
It has to start with zero slope.
So it would buzz alone
to a and then after b.
And what does it
have to do here?
If I graph the
solution to this guy
from zero to one it
starts with, it's
free, so nothing's
happening until I get to a.
Then what has to happen?
Let's see, if I'm
graphing u, it'll be ramp.
Right?
It'll be a ramp, yeah.
Because I've two derivatives.
And it has to ramp down by one,
so it'll ramp whatever it does.
I don't know where it stops.
Where does it?
Wait a minute.
I haven't practiced this.
So I start from the other end.
The other end is flat.
What's up?
They gotta meet here.
Oh, the other end is
flat, but not at zero!
Dumb, stupid.
Right.
Okay.
Yes, the other end
is flat, right.
And it's, oh yeah, look!
Oh, wonderful.
You see.
That slope dropped by
one and the slope there
increased by one back to zero.
Slope was zero.
It dropped to minus one
because of that load.
Now it increased
back to zero because
of this load with the minus
sign and there's a solution.
So that's a solvable problem.
Well, you say, okay, that
was a little surprising
to get an answer for
a singular problem.
And no, it can happen.
If we have a total
load zero it'll happen.
But, there is still a but,
that's not the only answer.
That picture is a solution.
But not the only one.
So what my point is
going to be, that when
the problem is singular,
if there's an answer,
you say great.
But then something has to
go wrong and what goes wrong
is too many answers.
So tell me some more, what other
graphs would draw solutions
to this problem.
I could shift, I could
lift the whole thing.
Here I've got a plus
C that I haven't used.
I could just do the
whole thing higher up.
Any of these.
These would all work.
It's like temperature.
I don't have an absolute
temperature here.
All I've got is, I would
have to-- It's not determined
because there's a plus C
that-- the plus C satisfied
everything.
A plus C, a constant has zero
slope, it has zero slope,
its second derivative is zero.
So it's like, unseen
by this equation.
And similarly can I
just make the analogy
as I always like to do with
discrete stuff, so suppose I--
Tell me a right-hand side
that we think would probably,
is this going to be the
same story for this guy?
Yes.
If I add those, where
I integrated there,
here I would add and I
get zero, zero, zero.
So this has to add to zero
if there's a solution.
So let me put for
example, [0,  1, -1].
That would be kind of like our
delta function in one direction
and our delta
function in the other.
I believe I can
solve that problem.
So I'm just carrying,
because I always
want you to see the discrete
one as well as the continuous.
Continuous involved
this integration.
The finite one just
involves adding.
The left side adds to zero
so the right-hand side better
add to zero.
That right-hand side does.
Tell me a solution.
Well, let me start out
with a seven there.
What's the next guy going to be?
See, I want seven.
Whatever I put there, I better
have a seven there, right?
Seven, seven, good.
Minus seven, plus 14, oh geez.
I didn't know this
was going to happen.
No, I want to get
the answer one.
What number goes there?
Six, is it six?
It's six, yeah, good.
Minus seven, 14,
minus six is that.
And now my claim is
that we'll come out
right on the third equation.
So far I've just
matched the first two.
Now this one gives
minus seven, plus six,
that's minus one, good.
So there's a solution.
And I'll leave
this problem alone
if you tell me the
rest, other solutions.
That [7, 7, 6] was a solution
to a singular problem
with a right-hand side
that had total load zero,
so it was okay.
But now that's a solution,
but there are more.
Tell me another one.
I can shift it, right?
I could make it [17, 17, 16].
I could add ten to everything.
Right?
That's the plus C that
I could do over there.
That can't change because
17 - 17 is still zero.
-17 + 16 will
still be minus one.
All good.
So actually that just
like helps our intuition,
and physically my
intuition is this.
That I've got this bar
and nothing's holding it.
So if I put a weight on it,
nothing to hold it, it'll just,
rigid motion will take
it out of sight, no good.
But if I put another
equal weight on it,
no it's not a weight.
What do I call it?
If I lift it at
that point, that's
the other delta function
that's going the other way,
then it will sit there.
But it would still
be in equilibrium
if I just moved it up to
there or moved it as I like.
I don't know if that is
kind of a dumb picture.
But it's saying what
we've said from math.
Well, you see where
your question led.
Yeah, thanks.
No, the integral, it was--
Watch what we integrated.
We integrated u''.
So that's not the area.
We integrated u'' and
got its integral was u'.
So that just told
us that a difference
in slopes at the ends, yeah.
Good, because our
intuition automatically
is if we're
integrating something,
we're finding an area.
But here, if it was u , then
I'd be finding the area under u,
but we integrated the
second derivative.
Right, good.
Now let's change the subject.
Yes, please.
Yeah, I guess so.
I'll try.
Let's see.
So my discrete
equation was like -u...
Yeah, so let's back
up to the beginning.
We've got this
minus sign and we're
using a second difference.
So second differences
have coefficients
one, minus two and one.
Now I'm reversing the
signs because of my minus.
So I have -u at some point.
Let's take that as
the point to the left.
Two u's at what I'll think
of as the center point,
minus u_(i-1).
Is the load at that center.
That center point
is i times delta x.
That's where I would be looking.
So now I'm using subscript.
It's a little bit of practice
then to take subscripts, take
this way of writing the equation
and convert it to a matrix way.
It's usually clearer once
you see it as a matrix.
Now this is happening
at all the points.
At i=1, let's say, I have
-u_0+2u_1-u_2 is f at, agrees
with the load at the
first mesh point.
That's the center,
the point h delta x.
And then if I want to back up
further, I would have -u_(-1),
but that doesn't really exist,
plus 2u_0-u_1 should match
the load at zero.
And so on forward.
But now I want to put in
the boundary condition.
That's what you want
me to do, right?
Put in this boundary condition.
So what am I going to take
as boundary condition?
It has to be some
approximation to u'(0)=0.
Maybe I'm never going
to get to minus one.
Maybe I don't need minus one.
That's right, yeah, exactly.
We did.
That's what we knew about it.
Sending it forward, we knew
about forward difference,
so I chose to do it.
But then I think better of it.
I chose to do it because it
made the point that we, that
at that boundary we were
introducing a higher order
error, first order error
that's going to wreck things.
I mean, it's going to spoil the,
this is second order accuracy.
And, but let me do
that first order.
So what shall I take?
I'm going to approximate
that by u-- Shall
I take this one
as I did in class?
Yes.
Ah, plus one, thanks, plus
one, right, thank you.
Thank you, good.
Okeydoke.
Alright.
This is how we got
to that equation.
If I now bring in this
boundary condition--
I guess I don't have to,
let me take your eye off
of that guy for the
moment, I think.
We're getting
beautiful music here.
Is it coming out of this box or?
No.
Anyway.
So I'm going to use
this boundary condition
to say, well okay,
if u_1 is u_0,
I'm going to replace
this u_0 by u_1.
This is the direct way.
I replaced that u_0 by u_1
in that first equation.
And then what I have is -u_1
and 2u_1, so that's the one
and I have the -u_2.
So do you see that that
equation, when I put those
together into a one, is
going to-- If this is u_1,
this is u_2, this is u_3
onwards, that first equation is
u_1-u_2 and that's
what I've got.
This is u_1-u_2.
So I did it.
I got to that matrix.
The matrix is actually
quite an important matrix.
But from the point
of view of accuracy
in solving this
differential equation,
it's not the greatest.
It's lost accuracy
at that point.
But the way to
recover it turned out
to be just a small adjustment at
the boundary, so not a problem.
Thanks.
That's good.
Yes, thanks.
Sorry?
When the boundary-- sorry.
Two boundary conditions
at the same point?
That's a good question.
So when would we have two?
So instead of a boundary
condition at zero
and a boundary condition at
one, you're putting them,
is that what you mean?
Put both boundary
conditions at the end.
Okay.
So that would be,
that would happen,
I would think that
would be more,
it would be very
typical in a, let
me see if there's
some space here, yeah.
That would be very
typical and we will do it,
can I change x to t?
Because that's what,
if I have some.
What does this
problem look like?
And u(0)=0 and u'(0)=0.
Both at the same, at the
start equals zero or whatever.
So what kind of a
problem is that?
Now these are, I would
say, initial values.
Initial values
instead of boundary
values, I now have
initial values.
And can I solve it?
Yes.
So I'm starting at time zero.
This is t=0.
I'm starting at rest.
No velocity and actually
no displacement and just
going forward in time.
So I could solve that
differential equation.
I'd be interested in the
corresponding difference
equation.
All fine.
It's a different
category of problem.
This is an initial
value problem.
It's like tracking some
mass that's, some satellite.
So that's what you're doing
in tracking a satellite
or a planet or something.
Yeah, tracking a
planet or a satellite.
You're solving
equations like this.
Forward in time.
You know the initial
position and you
know the forces acting on it.
Probably gravity.
And you go forward in time.
Yes.
What would the matrix be?
Good question.
What would the matrix look like?
So an electrical engineer
would call a problem like this,
and the kind of matrix that
I'm going to write down,
I think, would be called causal.
That word just popped into my
head, so let me mention it.
You know, part of science and
engineering, a big part of it
is learning language,
learning words.
And you have to learn
sort of the math language
and the engineering language
for whatever you're focusing on.
But it's good to also to
know a few other languages.
Electrical engineering
languages of filters
and causal and other things
that we'll see are important.
What would the matrix look like?
Here's what I think it would be.
I've made this a plus there
so I'll have to remember that.
I think, so I'm looking
at u_0, u_1-- No.
Well, u_0 I actually
know, so let
me start with u_1,
u_2, u_3, u_4.
What would a typical-- Equal
sum, right side, f_1, f_2,
f_3, f_4.
What do you think, what kind
of a matrix am I going to get?
Before I put it in there.
This is a good question.
What's the shape of this matrix?
It's going to be triangular.
Instead of being symmetric
it's going to be triangular.
I'm going to find, let's
see, a typical value
would be, say, u_3 because
I've used a plus sign, oops!
I can't make myself do it right.
1, -2, 1.
That would say u_3-2u_2+u_1
would be the new force.
This is the kind of
thing we're going to get.
One, maybe one something.
I don't know what this is.
This is up in the boundary,
in the initial values.
But from now on it'll
be below the diagonal.
It'll be 1, -2, 1.
Do you see?
We're marching.
We're marching forward.
We start by knowing
these and then
the equation tells
us the next one.
Then the equation
tells us the next one.
That's what initial
value problems do.
You're told how you begin
and you take a step,
you take a step, take
a step every time.
And the new value just needs
to know the older values.
Do you see the big difference
between that and our problems
here?
Our problem is
looking left and right
looking for back and forward.
Back for one condition,
forward for another.
We start with one, but
we're, it's more of a,
it's like a hitting problem.
We start forward, marching
forward in our problems,
but we have to hit the
other end correctly.
We don't know the slope, we
don't know the starting slope,
we know what we want to hit.
Whereas these problems, we're
told how we start and we just
follow it in time.
So that's the difference here.
Yeah, sure, okay.
That's true.
So this'll be known.
Yeah, that'll be known.
Yeah. u_1 will also be known.
Yeah, and really, maybe
I should have got,
let me put even the
other known one.
So we know this, we know this.
So those are sort
of not in our, yeah,
that shouldn't be in
our problem somehow.
No, I think, what would
we get in the end?
You're always looking backwards.
That's the point.
Lower triangular matrices
are always looking,
they only look backwards
for earlier values
and then they give
you the current value.
So that's why lower triangular
matrices are so easy to invert.
No problem.
If it's lower triangular, you
just, like, march forward.
And if it's upper triangular,
which way do you march?
So if you have an upper
triangular problem,
suppose I gave you
the problem, let
me make it upper triangular.
So x+y+z=7.
2y+3z=12 and z=17.
So that's upper triangular.
Where do we start
in solving that one?
From the bottom.
From the right-hand
end, the bottom.
And we march backwards in time.
And what I was saying
about A, well L times U,
yeah, this is worth seeing.
What I was saying about A=LU,
it was, you remember that?
Those letters?
What that was saying was
that this matrix that's
looking both ways can be written
as a product of a matrix L
that looks behind for old values
and you can go forward with it.
And a matrix U, like this one,
this upper triangular, 1, 1, 1,
zeroes below that diagonal,
that you go backward with.
Somehow that's appealing.
That's like aesthetic to
break up a two-way problem
into a problem that marches
one way and then the other.
And of course, that's
what elimination aims for,
is this problem that it can
solve by, the words would be,
back substitution.
When you've started with
your original problem, got
to this one, then you just
have a back substitution,
you go backwards.
Oh, so much, I'll mention
the Kalman filter.
That's a similar process
of going forward,
that's called prediction.
Going backward, that's
called smoothing.
And so, Kalman
had the great idea
that he could break
these problems that
were fundamental in
space computations
into prediction and smoothing.
Once again, we've got off.
Yes?
Oh, the beam.
Let me help you even
more before the question.
I said it's better to
draw the beam this way.
I like the beam better this way.
Because the point of the beam
problem is loads are acting --
and we'll see this,
of course, later --
loads are acting perpendicular
to the direction of the beam.
That's why the beam bends.
So it'll bend a little, right?
And that is what leads
us, its bending moments
and other stuff.
If you haven't met
beams, well, it'll
be great to just have a
very, half a lecture about,
or maybe a lecture about beams.
That gives a fourth
order equation
that I'll write down again.
Fourth derivative
equal the load.
Now, ready.
Yeah, now here I don't
have the negative sign.
Because once I've got
second derivatives twice,
so the second derivative
is, in some way, negative.
I'll complete that
sentence in a second.
Somehow the second
derivative, which
is the guy that has the
1, -2, 1, somehow that's
a negative thing.
But fourth derivative
is second derivative
of the second derivative.
Yeah, do you want to tell me
what the numbers would be?
As long as we're wildly looking
forward to fourth derivatives,
just, it helps.
Do you want to guess what will
a typical row of the matrix B
when I go to finite
differences, fourth differences?
Probably you've never
seen a fourth difference.
You may not have seen
second differences before.
That was a big deal, then, to
introduce second differences.
Those 1, -2, 1's.
That was second differences.
Fourth?
Yeah, 1, 4, 6, 4,
1 with minus sign.
1, -4, 6, -4, and 1.
In some way, I would get
that by squaring this guy.
So that would be a
fourth difference.
Oh, what's the deal with
boundary conditions?
What are you figuring,
on beams, beam problems,
for a fourth order equation
and a matrix that's
stretching out further.
What's going to happen at
the left-hand boundary?
I guess my specific question
is, how many boundary conditions
do I now need?
Four.
And the typical is
two at each end.
That's the balanced way.
That's the way that would make
this matrix sort of symmetric.
So maybe at this end I
say it's held at zero
and maybe it's just
sitting on a log there.
Right?
That boundary condition I
would call simply supported.
That boundary condition
says that u(0)=0.
Because it's sitting there.
And but the slope
doesn't have to be zero.
What does have to be zero there?
Yeah, sort of the
bending moment.
Nobody's here
twisting it, right?
So the other condition
in that picture
would be second
derivative equal zero.
Maybe my point is that now
you see what I said before,
that getting the boundary
conditions into the problem
is often the hardest part.
Because I have to
replace u(0)=0,
that shouldn't be
too hard to do.
But I have to use this
other condition somehow,
it's going to screw up
the 1, -4, 6, -4, 1.
I'll have two boundary
rows at the top,
two boundary rows at the bottom.
I don't want to
go further today.
But I think maybe
just mentioning
this gives you the
picture of sort
of the how things fit together.
We would still have some
nice constant diagonals
in the middle,
but now we'll have
two boundary rows at each end.
So that's something to come.
Yes, now back to reality,
which is, any questions?
Lower triangular guy, yeah.
What do I mean by
marching forward?
So let's see.
I'll replace this.
Let's see it better.
I would replace this by maybe
u, I'll use a different letter,
n+1.
At u_(n+1)-2u_n+u_(n-1)
is some right-hand side
if there's a force
acting on my thing.
So f_n maybe.
By marching forward, I just
mean that this equation--
that I can go in order.
I can start with u_0 and u_1.
They come from the
boundary conditions.
Then this equation
will tell me u_2.
I use the equation.
With n as one.
This says u_2, some u_1's, some
u_0's, f_1's, all that I know.
In other words, once I get
started, I'm on a roll.
If I have two boundary
conditions to get me started,
then the equation tells me u_2.
And then the next time,
u_3-2u_2+u_1, I can find u_3.
So I can get those,
I can go forever.
If you give me enough to
start on, two things to start,
then I march forward.
Whereas in our problems, we've
only got one thing to start on
and we've got one goal to hit.
And that's why we have to solve
the whole system together.
This is, we can solve
it step-by-step.
This is way faster of course.
To be able to just
go forward in time.
I'll mention that the topic
of initial value problems
and finite differences for
them, we can't get to that.
So we're seeing a
little bit here,
but it's done properly in
18.086 in the second semester
is the initial value
problem start part.
And that has it's own
interesting questions.
Somehow we've talked about
fourth order equations,
initial value problems.
But no homework problems.
So I'm ready for,
or even related.
But that's fine with me.
Is there a question?
Yeah, thanks.
Or it doesn't have
to be a homework
question, another question.
Oh, good question.
You mean I should just
send the homework out
to Natick where MATLAB is.
Do you know that MATLAB
is just 15 miles away?
I almost get there, I
live 2/3 of the way there.
Yeah, so we could just send
the whole thing out there
and get it back.
That would save a lot of work.
I suppose, I'm okay.
Why should I say no?
Anything MATLAB can do
and you can make it do,
I'm okay with that.
I don't see that you have to
do things by hand if you've
got a better way.
That's okay.
And then probably the
answer gets printed
and you can graph it.
So that's fine.
So I mean, somehow a course like
this has got two parts to it.
Applied math has
two parts to it.
The modeling part, set up the
equation, think, what is it
you're supposed to do.
And then, step two is do it.
The numerical part,
the computing part.
And that's where MATLAB,
Python, Fortran, whatever,
is going to do a lot
of the heavy lifting.
Was there another question?
So that first
homework was certainly
very general intentionally.
Because I'm hoping you
will read the book.
The lecture, you'll be
able to match the lectures
with the book even later
on when they separate
a little or separate more.
You'll see what we're doing.
And those, the
homework problems,
you should look at some
of the others just to see.
Do I know how to do that?
Right.
Let's stop here for
this first review.
I'm sure we'll have more--
questions will build up
for the second week.